Strom wäre auch nicht schlecht sobald
sie mal oder so lange wir uns direkt
abstellt benutzt man natürlich Strom
[Musik]
wie heißt denn eigentlich deine Puppe
hat sie noch keinen Namen wie wäre es
mit purple
weil ihre Haare purple sind lila
lila und grün purple and green
Länder
Menschen wie heißt sie
er fällt mir gleich wieder ein gefällt
dir gleich wieder meinst du deine Puppe
will so einen
Glasur oder ohne
mit und Pikachu
viel
die sind ja lecker
okay
darf ich sie einfach purple ja
wie
creepy Girl oh okay meinst du creepy
Girl will mit Glas oder ohne
und sollen wir das Rezept zu diesen
saftigen
schokoladigen Mini gugelhups mit der
Community Teil sollen die Zuschauer auch
das Rezept erfahren was sagst du
ja
also wenn Ihr auch dieses Rezept haben
wollt dann würde ich sagen backen wir
jetzt diese Mini Gugelhupf zusammen und
ich zeige euch mal die Zutaten für den
Rührteig für den Teig nehme ich ein Ei
50 g Zucker etwas Vanilleextrakt und
eine Prise Salz jeweils 50 g
Sonnenblumenöl und Traubensaft oder
Rotwein 80g Mehl plus Backpulver oder
nimmt das backmehl und 15 Gramm Kakao
ich finde die sind echt überschaubar und
so ein Ei und ganz wenige Zutaten für
eine Backform aber es sind ja auch
minigols zuerst nehmt ihr jetzt das Ei
mit dem Zucker Salz und Vanilleextrakt
die Zutaten werden kurz verrührt und
eigentlich ist es auch ein Grundrezept
für die Backform muss ich sagen denn ihr
könnt dann das Kakaopulver weglassen und
bisschen mehr Mehl nehmen und statt
Traubensaft oder Rotwein könnt ihr
einfach Buttermilch nehmen oder zum
Beispiel Limonade Sprudelwasser was auch
immer und könnte einfach eure
Geschmacksrichtung der Wahl zu
orange
Spekulatius Vanille was ihr möchte
Strom wäre auch nicht schlecht sobald
man oder so lange wir uns da nicht
abstellt benutzt man natürlich Strom
[Musik]
unglaublich wie schnell so ein Ei
schaumig gerührt ist
dann kommen die zwei Flüssigkeiten dazu
[Musik]
und dann Mehl mit Backpulver
plus Kakao einrühren
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier meine Backform
das ist die abgekupfert Backform und da
ist die Beschichtung echt richtig gut
natürlich müsst ihr trotzdem die
Backform einfetten aber ich muss sagen
da habe ich jetzt glaube ich zwei Jahre
lang die Beschichtung getestet und die
ist wirklich der Hammer also es gab
etliche Versuche mit mehr Material dass
die Bleche dicker sind dass sie die
Wärme besser verteilen und dann war die
Beschichtung nicht so wie ich sie wollte
und jetzt muss ich sagen nach zwei
Jahren haben wir echt die perfekte
Beschichtung trotzdem ein bisschen
einfetten natürlich und so eine
Beschichtung hält auch viel viel länger
wenn ihr die Bleche immer per Hand spült
denn alles was in die Spülmaschine kommt
geht schneller kaputt muss man sagen ich
hatte sie trotzdem während dieser
versuche immer wieder in der
Spülmaschine um natürlich zu checken ob
sie die Spülmaschine auch aushalten
halten sie aus aber trotzdem ist immer
besser wir spielen
dann könnt ihr jetzt bei der Mini
Gugelhupfform entweder einen Mini
Eisportionierer nehmen oder zum Beispiel
die Dosierflasche zum Einfüllen geht
beides gut also bei der Mini ICE ICE wie
heißt Portionierer Eisportionierer beim
ist es genau eine Portion voll und mit
der Dosierflasche geht aber auch super
da müsste nur darauf achten dass keine
Klümpchen im Teig sind hast du diesmal
den Kakao gesehen
ich dachte mir so eine risk no fun haha
wenn jetzt klümchen drin sind dann
ärgert mich natürlich aber
ich hatte irgendwie keine Lust den Kakao
zu sehen damals gleich sehen
aber ich empfehle euch den Kakao zu
sehen da ist immer so klumpig
und diese Menge passt perfekt für dieses
komplette Blech und ich finde es halt
immer cool wenn man irgendwie gerade
noch Gäste erwartet oder man will eben
doch noch schnell was backen was süßes
kleines was schnell gehen soll dann kann
man diese mini-kugels backen wir
brauchen nur ein Ei dafür und so ein
paar kleine weniger Zutaten und dann hat
man Blech voll Köstlichkeiten
immer so knapp bis unterm Rand
[Musik]
dann kommen sie jetzt schon in den
vorgeheizten Backofen bei 170°c
die minigogeln sind gebacken das geht
auch richtig schnell neun Minuten
Backzeit haben sie noch gebraucht jetzt
habe ich sie aus dem Ofen raus sie sind
noch ein bisschen warm aber das macht
nichts man kann das nämlich direkt auf
einen abkühlgitter stürzen
sieht man auch gut geht alles schön raus
und dann hier einfach abkühlen lassen
und ihr könnt jetzt davon gerne die
doppelte Menge machen und zum Beispiel
die donut-form nehmen dann habt ihr
nämlich schöne Google nee nicht Googles
Rotwein Donuts oder Rotwein Google
ich finde das Wort einfach witzig
ich frage mich immer wer auf so Name
kommt so Glück hatte sie eine Bedeutung
naja solange die hier Auskühlen das wird
jetzt auch nicht lange dauern kann ich
schon mal eine Glasur anrühren dafür
habe ich jetzt hier Puderzucker und
etwas Zitronensaft eine Schokoglasur
würde auch gut passen aber ich will dass
die farblich so ein bisschen heller
werden also schön rosa werden deswegen
bisschen Zitronensaft zum Puderzucker
könnte das schon mal verrühren
und dann gebe ich lebensmittelfarpaste
dazu ein bisschen rosa bisschen rot bis
ich eine schöne Farbe bekommen
und die Glasur einfach so weit mit
Zitrone verdünnen bis sie schön fließt
und nicht zu dünn dabei zu dick werden
[Musik]
oh mein Gott
it's a match
also bei so viel Mini hier muss ich
sogar eine Miniform nehmen
okay die sind jetzt auch schon abgekühlt
und dann tauche ich die jetzt da rein
und ich habe hier noch dieses Scarlett
metallic Flex das ist einfach Schokolade
die überzogen ist und dann einfach
diesen metallischen diese metallische
Optik hat richtig schön und vor allem
ist es schön weil es eben Schokolade
essen gut schmeckt und nicht irgendwie
so ein Zuckerstreusel der so fest und
hart auf den Zähnen ist dass man sich
irgendwie die Zähne ausbeißen einfach
nur ein schöner Schokoladengeschmack
dann tauche ich das jetzt hier rein
das wäre jetzt was für
ella's Barbie Tisch ach so ne hat
Barbies out lol
kuchenkätzchen für die lol
Schubs
richtig süß
[Musik]
es dauert schon ein bisschen lange
ja aber Mini Googles sind süß
ihr könnt auch nur Donuts machen mir ist
es egal aber ich mache jetzt meine
es wird eigentlich nur so zu mir so ein
bisschen raushängen
[Musik]
ich hätte gerne eine Mini Barbie Küche
die aussieht wie meine Küche unsere
minibarbe mit einer Sally
Pikachu der hatte schon gegessen
und creepy Girl hat sie auch gegessen
[Musik]
mal schauen
ja die ist auch gerade schade dass man
nicht noch ein kleineren Tortenständer
haben vielleicht bauen wir mal einen
okay für deine Puppen fürs Puppenhaus
okay
gut also ihr könnt jetzt auch gerne die
mini-kugels nachmachen oder wenn ihr
möchtet das Rezept verdoppeln und Mini
Donuts draus zubereiten Muffins oder
Cupcakes gehen natürlich auch aber ich
finde so eine Mini Portion so ein Mini
google ist echt schön macht Spaß den
zubereiten und zu dekorieren ihr könnt
dann auch gerne ohne Glasur lassen und
einfach nur mit süßen Schnitte kurieren
dann wünschen wir euch ganz viel Spaß
beim Nachbacken und wir sehen uns wieder
beim nächsten Mal tschüss
tschüss
jeweils weiter spielen
mit denen
[Musik]